all right guys I'm actually in San
Francisco right now I have my reasons
just trust me uh but as you probably
have heard Governor Ron DeSantis has
just announced officially his candidacy
to be president of the United States he
did it live on a Twitter spaces uh with
little-known tech entrepreneur Elon Musk
here's the announcement
well I am running for president of the
United States to lead our Great American
comeback look we know our country's
going in the wrong direction we see it
with our eyes and we feel it in our
bones our Southern borders collapse
drugs are pouring into the country our
cities are being hollowed out by spiking
crime the federal government's making it
harder for the average family to make
ends meet and to attain and maintain a
middle-class lifestyle and our president
well he lacks Vigor flounders in the
face of our nation's challenges and he
takes his cues from the woke mob I don't
think it has to be this way American
decline is not inevitable it is a choice
and we should choose a new Direction a
path that will lead to American
revitalization we must restore sanity to
our nation this means embracing fiscal
and economic sanity stop pricing
hard-working Americans out of a good
standard of living through inflationary
borrow print and spending policies and
please Embrace American Energy
Independence this also means replacing
the woke mind virus with reality facts
and enduring principles Merit must Trump
identity politics we must return
normalcy to our communities America is a
sovereign country our borders must be
respected we cannot have foreigners
pouring into our country illegally by
the millions we cannot allow drug
cartels to poison our population with
fentanyl public deserve safe communities
and Law and Order must be maintained in
American cities we can't have inmates
running the Asylum and we must reject
attacks on the men and women of law
enforcement we also must re-establish
Integrity in our institutions this
includes the military I'm proud to be a
Navy veteran and Iraq veteran and I
Revere our services but when revered
institutions like those in our military
are more concerned with matters not
Central to the mission whether it's
global warming or gender ideology and
pronoun sounds morale declines and
recruiting suffers and you need to
eliminate these distractions and we need
to get focused on the core Mission we
also cannot have true constitutional
government if the most significant
issues are decided by the whims of
unelected bureaucrats rather than the
people's elected representatives
re-establishing Integrity in our
institutions means we must reinvigorate
our constitutional system by returning
the government to its rightful owners We
the People no social or Eco
transformation without representation
truth needs to be our foundation Common
Sense can no longer be an uncommon
virtue and in Florida we proved it could
be done we chose facts over fear
education over indoctrination Law and
Order over rioting and disorder we held
the line when Freedom hung into balance
and we're thriving as a result Florida
is the nation's fastest growing State
we're number one in net in migration
number one in new business formations
recently ranked number one in education
we have a 50-year low crime rate and one
of the lowest tax in debt per capita in
America but we also understand governing
is not entertainment it's not about
building a brand or virtue signaling it
is about delivering results and our
results in Florida have been second to
none and we can and we must deliver big
results for America I pledge to be an
energetic executive that will take on
the important issues Biden's pursued
inflationary policies that are hurdy
working people we will reverse those
policies and we'll build an economy
where working Americans can achieve a
good standard of living Biden's opened
the southern border and allowed massive
amounts of drugs to pour into the
country we'll shut down the Border
construct the border wall and hold the
drug cartels accountable bidens Embrace
medical authoritarianism such as
unconstitutional covid vacs mandates we
will ensure that those violations of
Liberty can never happen again Biden's
allowed woke ideology to drive his
agenda we will never surrender to the
woke mob and we will leave woke ideology
in the Dustbin of History Biden's also
politicized the military and caused
recruiting to plummet we will eliminate
ideological agendas from our military
Focus the military on the core Mission
and we will reverse the poor recruiting
Trends finally Biden's weaponized the
power of the administrative state to
advance his left-wing agenda we will
reconstitutionalize the executive branch
and we'll bring the administrative state
to heal now you can't do any of that if
you don't win there is no substitute for
victory we must end the culture of
losing that has infected the Republican
party in recent years the tired dogmas
of the past are inadequate for a vibrant
future we must look forward not
backwards we need the courage to lead
feed and we must have the strength to
win and to voters who are participating
in this primary process my pledge to you
is this if you nominate me you can set
your clock to January 20th 2025 at High
Noon because on the west side of the U.S
Capitol I will be taking the oath of
office as the 47th president of the
United States no excuses I will get the
job done now these past few years have
given me a new appreciation for the
fragility of our freedoms I never
thought I would see things in America
that we saw during the covid-19 pandemic
but our founding fathers were keenly
aware of the fragility of Freedom when
they framed our constitution they came
to armed with having studied the history
of every Republic in the history of
mankind and they notice that all of
those experiments only had one thing in
common and it was this every single one
of them had failed and so they knew it
fell to our country the United States of
America to determine whether people
could really govern themselves elves
could we have a society based on the
idea that our rights are god-given not
government granted and that Society
functions based on the rule of law not
the rule of individual men and when Dr
Benjamin Franklin walked out of that
convention he was asked did you deliver
a republic or a monarchy he said a
republic if you can keep it they knew
Freedom didn't run on autopilot they
knew each generation would have a
responsibility to safeguard freedom and
it's our responsibility to do so at this
important juncture in our nation's
history we have a lot of work to do to
ensure the country gets back on track I
ask everybody listening to please join
me on this Mission please invest in our
campaign by going to Ron desantis.com
and making a donation thank you God
bless and I look forward to the
discussion
so look guys there it is I think this is
a game-changing way of getting in the
race nobody freaking expected that I
don't know thought maybe he'd be
standing in front of Disney or go to DC
and do it or do it from Miami or from
the governor's mansion in Tallahassee uh
but I think that this is the right way
to do it Tech forward going for those
new voters the disaffected Liberals
showing there is a new world on the
horizon if we're brave enough to just
get there no bs No Nonsense no name
calling and uh I'm very excited and I
really do think we have a chance to make
America Florida that's the goal it's
going to be a crazy year and a half I
was actually supposed to interview the
governor tomorrow we can't do that on my
side because of travel but obviously
we'll have some other things coming up
with him over the next couple months and
let's see what happens here we go